-Our next guest is a talented
actor you know from his work on
shows such as "Supernatural"
and "Smallville."
He joins the Emmy-nominated
series "The Boys,"
which is now streaming
exclusively on
Amazon Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-The most idiotic of them all.
-What do you say, Gunpowder?
Give them the Fourth of July.
-Let's light 'em up,
Soldier Boy.
-Please put that down.
-Oh, well, I didn't realize
they made case officers
as pretty as you.
We're just having some fun.
-Our munitions dump
is in that direction.
You're about to blow up
half the camp.
Put it down -- now.
-I do like the assertive type.
You know, with a figure like
yours, you are wasted down here.
-Please welcome to the show
Jensen Ackles, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Such a pleasure to
have you here.
How you doing?
-Hey. Good. Great. Grand.
-I am a big fan of this show.
This show is gory.
This show is graphic.
This show is also
very funny at times.
Were you familiar with it
before they reached out?
-I was.
Eric Kripke,
who's the showrunner,
created a little show a few
years ago called "Supernatural."
-Yeah.
-And so I was certainly
friends with the boss.
And when he came out with
the show, I was like,
"I'm gonna have to watch
another Kripke show."
'Cause he's done -- You know,
he went off and did "Timeless."
He went off
and did "Revolution."
The guy --
He can't stop working.
But this one really is him
with the gloves off.
And it shows.
Because it is everything
that he couldn't do
on network television.
-It is -- You have
a million-dollar voice
for superheroes,
and I feel like the clip was
a perfect illustration of that.
But you have done some
superhero voice work before.
Not acting, but you did some
DC Comic stuff.
You did Red Hood.
-Yep.
In fact, I just spent about
3 1/2 hours in the studio
yesterday doing Batman.
-Oh, wow.
You do it for Batman, too?
Look at that.
That's a big deal.
-That is a big deal.
I don't want to drop that ball.
-Yeah. Now, that, of course,
is nice because
you just get to do the voice.
Here, you have to get
the gear on.
It seems like as far as
the costumes on this show go,
you did okay,
'cause some of them are
maybe a little bit less fun
to put on.
-Yeah, it was -- I got the
nice one, I would --
I can still move around.
There was no leotard, no rubber,
no suit that you had to peel off
at the end of the day.
-Right.
-That being said,
while we were fitting it --
'Cause these things
are works of art
and they take quite a bit of
time to really put together.
The super-suit
costume designer, LJ --
she was starting to put
the stuff together and was like,
"Are you gonna give me some --
you know, give me some muscles?"
Like, I see these suits,
and they are clearly outlined
with, you know,
added muscles.
-No, I would definitely show up
assuming muscles
would be there already.
-Yeah. And then -- But instead,
she just lightly taps me
on the shoulder and she goes,
"You're going to bring me
some muscles in April."
-Wait. How much time --
When was that?
When was that conversation?
-This was like October.
-Oh, my God.
That's not enough time.
-Well, it was.
-Yeah. Oh, wow.
-I was like,
"Challenge accepted."
-Yeah. I'm sorry that I saw
the clip and I was like,
"That wasn't enough time."
-Yeah, thanks, man.
So, apparently, it wasn't.
-You mentioned that
this is a show --
-Noddle-armed Soldier Boy there.
-This is --
Obviously, I would say
there's not an episode
in the show that you don't see
five or 10 examples of something
that couldn't be on
network television.
Obviously, you mentioned you're
friends with the showrunner.
Did he -- Was there anything
he asked you to do
that you thought, "Oh, man,
this is not friendship"?
-So, yeah, if anybody's ever
thinking of coming on to
a Kripke show and portraying
one of his characters,
never tell him
that something bothers you.
-Oh, interesting.
-He will write to it full force.
-Oh, like, he'll -- If you have,
like, one fear thing --
-Oh, yeah, if you're like,
"I don't like fluid
all over me,"
he's like, "Oh, okay!
Okay. Got it."
-Yeah. So if you do it,
be like, "I hate cake."
-Right, right, right, right.
Needless to say,
he found my line very quickly
and then continued to
write to it.
-So, this is
a no-spoiler situation,
but for anybody
who finishes the season,
we should be able to pinpoint
the moment where you --
he has found the weakness?
-Yeah, I mean, let's --
Yeah, without any spoilers,
I mean, it's just
odd sexual positions.
-Alright, great.
Now, that is troubling,
'cause that means,
based on everything
you've said so far,
that you went to him and said,
"There's just -- I got
two sexual positions I hate.
Whatever you do, Kripke,
just know this one
and this one are off limits."
-Well, they --
And this is how really advanced
this whole process is,
is I would get e-mails with
just stick figures in positions.
I would be like,
"Oh, 'A' and 'B' are out.
I'm sorry. I can't.
I have children."
-That's right.
You do --
And we were talking backstage.
We each have three kids.
You've got two 5s and a 9.
-I got two 5s and a 9.
-So, this is obviously
just off limit.
They cannot watch this show.
-Oh, yeah, no.
-Is there anything --
I mean, they must be aware.
-My parents don't watch
this show.
My mom better not.
-Is there anything
that you could show them
where they think, "Oh, that's
cool that dad's doing that"?
-So, a few years back,
"Supernatural" did
a crossover with "Scooby-Doo."
-Alright, perfect.
-And, I mean,
they were animating me
as my character on
"Supernatural,"
but at the end of the day,
they were just animating me.
So dad is animated
with Scooby-Doo on a cartoon
that my kids just adore.
-And you got to voice it?
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah.
-And they weren't
thrown off by that?
Because I have some friends
who have done voice-over work,
and they say their kids --
they don't like that moment.
-Well, 'cause I have
actor friends
that do voices of characters in
movies that they have watched
that they're very familiar with.
And I'll be like,
"Hey, hey, talk to my buddy."
And then they're like, "Why is
that person talking to me?"
So -- Or they'll come over to
the house and be like,
"This is so-and-so,"
and they're like,
"No, that doesn't look anything
like a little dog."
-Yeah. Well, that's
the -- I've said the same thing,
where I'm like,
"I've actually --
Yeah, the guy
who does that bear voice --
he's been on my show."
And I show them a clip,
and they're like,
"Oh, he's a human."
-Unimpressed.
Unimpressed at this point.
-I do want to mention --
You know,
you alluded to "Supernatural."
15 years, over 300 episodes.
This is, like, an unheard of
accomplishment for
you, yourself, and everybody
who did that show.
And, obviously,
an incredible fan base.
I don't think any show could be
on 15 years without one.
That must have been
a tremendous ride.
-It was.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Yeah.
-Give it up.
-Yeah, I think we topped out
at 327 episodes
of prime-time television,
which was a long, long run.
And it was fantastic.
There was a reason why I think
we all stuck around, though,
because we just
truly enjoyed it.
It was a family.
You know, we --
I spent birthdays,
and we spent holidays
and we -- There was just --
We went through so much together
as a crew and a cast
that by the end of it,
it was a really sad goodbye,
but something that we all felt
like we really earned.
-That's really cool.
-Yeah.
-A shorter run,
but also a big fan base --
you did three years on
"Days of Our Lives."
-[ Laughs ]
Nobody remembers that.
-Do you get recognized, though?
-So, okay, funny story. No.
-Okay.
-Until about two weeks ago.
-When I was on
a flight back from Europe --
we were over there doing some
press for "The Boys,"
and a lovely flight attendant
kind of, like --
You know how they look at you
and they're like, "Ehhh..."
-Yeah.
-Like, "Ehhhhhh."
So I'm thinking
maybe "Supernatural,"
maybe "The Boys," I don't know.
And, so, I'm coming out of
the bathroom,
and they're there in the galley.
And he says,
"Days of Our Lives."
And I immediately was like,
"You're not even old enough
to remember me."
And, immediately,
he went right into it.
He was like,
"What's Marlena like?"
And, so, I sat there speaking,
you know, like,
taking up space in the galley
there, sipping coffee.
-Well, I mean,
I would imagine -- For 15 years,
you've had to answer so many
questions about "Supernatural."
It must have been a nice break
to go back to the "Days" days.
-Yeah, I had to go through
the files in the brain there
and come up with some stories.
But, yeah, David, if you're out
there, that was a pleasure.
It was enjoyable.
-And I'm sure, your next flight,
you'll be answering questions
about "The Boys."
Hey, thanks so much
for being here.
It's been a real pleasure
talking to you
and having you on.
Jensen Ackles.
The first three episodes of
the third season of "The Boys"
are streaming now, with
new episodes available Fridays
on Amazon Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with music from Tove Lo.